Casting on if you are a hand knitter,
you probably know that there are
lots of different cast-on methods.
The same is true for machine knitters.
Even in crochet, you often work
with a foundation row to get started.
There are two basic cast-on types
open cast-on's and closed cast-on's.
Open is usually a very quick
way of getting started.
A provisional type cast on is another
somewhat open cast on where you can pick
up stitches and finish
knitting at a later time.
Maybe you'll start your garment
on the machine with an open cast
on and then pick up the stitches on hand
knitting needles and create
a pretty ruffle or ribbing by hand.
There are lots of reasons to use an open
on. But more often we don't want live
stitches, we want a permanent, closed
finished edge that will be attractive on its own.
Part of the decision on which cast-on method to use is the purpose of your
edge. Will this edge be
the finished edge of your garment?
Will you be picking up stitches
and maybe working a trim?
Will you be crocheting around
the edge of your item?
Will this edge be hidden
by something else?
There's a lot to consider.
Here's the open cast-on that many
beginners are taught. It's good
for casting out a few stitches quickly.
Make sure your carriage is set to neutral,
it's set for plain knitting.
Thread the tensioning
system in the carriage.
Depending on your yarn,
said the carriage tension to somewhere
around the middle of the dial.
Put 20 to 30 stitches into working
position.
Holding the tail of the yarn below
the carriage with one hand push
the carriage across the needles from right
to left, your needles
should look like this.
If your tension is too loose,
the loops are going to be loose and sloppy
and they may not form stitches well.
Too tight of a tension will
cause problems as well.
Now, place your ravel cord across
the stitches between the needle hooks
and the gate pegs. You don't want the cord
in the hooks just next to the hooks.
Pull down on the ends of the ravel
cord and hold the yarn tail as well.
You'll want the cord to be below
the needles holding those loops in place
now, knit 4 or 5 rows.
Remove the ravel cord.
You'll see now why ravel cord
needs to be strong and slippery.
Continue knitting.
Here are the live stitches
that are left behind.
Now, another negative for this particular
method is that it's difficult to use
over a large number of stitches.
It's important that you put pressure
on the main yarn loops with the ravel
cord. So if you have a lot of stitches,
it's hard to get that pressure
in the middle of the piece.
So the stitches knit properly.
Let's try a different method.
Many knitting machines come
with a cast-on comb.
This allows you to quickly work an open
cast on over as many stitches
as you'd like. As before,
Make sure your carriage is set to neutral.
The tension is set according to your yarn.
Put 20 or 30 needles into work, thread
up your machine and knit across
from right to left.
Next, hang the teeth of your cast-on comb
in the loops of the yarn
from front to back.
Be sure to catch all the loops
so each needle knits properly.
Knit back from left to right.
Like the ravel cord,
the cast on puts pressure on those
loops so the stitches will knit.
Did all your stitches knit?
Here's a problem,
if you look closely,
my cast on Combe has some bent teeth,
and I didn't catch each loop.
Now that I'm knitting, you can see that
the stitches aren't forming correctly.
This cast on comb could be used for other
techniques, but it's in really bad shape
and can't really be used for an open cast
on even hanging the teeth in the other
direction from the back isn't helping.
There is no hope for this cast on comb.
As you can probably tell,
I'm not a fan of open cast on methods.
Let's move on to closed cast-ons.
They can be plain or fancy.
Really fast or somewhat tedious.
Close cast on methods are what
you will use most of the time.